A brief announcement today after or
today at 11:30. So this will be before
but today at 11:30 right here in
this masid we will be holding the janza
salah for our brother Gilani. He was
killed in a traffic accident on
Friday night.
So, , this is brother Ali's son. He's
not here, , right now, , probably
preparing for this, but he's a young
man, 29 years old.
[Silence]
Subhanah.
So that will be tonight. Today at 11:30
inshallah the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us whoever makes salat
upon his brother for him is a of reward.
So this would be a mountain of
good deeds of merits and if the person
makes janza and then follows the janza
to the cemetery and to its end then he
will have two.
This is very important. This is one of
the rights of the Muslim upon us. And
we are required to follow the janaza as
we would wish that somebody follow
our janaza because ultimately we need
each other. We need each other's dua.
ate.
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that anyone who passes away and
40 men who do not associate anything
unto Allah in their worship of he make
salat janza over them except that Allah
will accept their
interession on his behalf. And in other
wordings of the narration 100 men and
the difference is that the weaker
these the community is in sunnah in
worship in knowledge
the weaker their intercession will
be. So some communities it will be 40
men, some communities it will need 50 or
60 or 100 or even more. But the point is
is that we should try to attend at least
the salah. At least the salah especially
in our community is a very small
community. It's not big. We don't have
janazes every day. Maybe once every few
months. So it's good for us to go out of
our way even if we lose money to do so.
right to go out of our way to at least
be here to make salah. Again, that will
be today here at 11:30 inshallah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the chapter regarding the
instances in which it is preferred
preferred not obligatory preferred that
a person bathe. How many instances
obligate necessitate bathing?
Five. And how many does the author
mention of
you know encouraged
instances of bathing?
Eight. Eight. Right. And so we are on
number five today. Yesterday was number
four. We mentioned was burying a
disbeliever. And burying a disbeliever
doesn't just mean attending a funeral.
We're speaking about actually physically
burying the body. This instance is
highly highly
remote in our in our time in our
place that somebody would be involved in
this. But nonetheless, it is another
point that I'd to make before we
continue. when we read a book like
this and we mention general things,
we're mentioning general rulings.
Meaning this is the ruling in a general
set of circumstances in an ordinary set
of circumstances.
These are not to be understood under
extreme or specific or outlandish
circumstances. If a person were to have
extreme or atl out outlandish
circumstances, what do they do?
What do they do?
Huh?
If a person has something that is out of
the ordinary happen to them, what do
they do to know how to deal with this
issue?
Ask
Books will never take the scholar's
place ever. Ever. Doesn't matter how
many books you read. It will never
happen. And a scholar will never live
his life and
give out everything that he has ever.
Doesn't matter if he lived five
lifetimes, he would not be able to teach
or
you know give out everything that he
has. But the point here that's important
is that when we say for instance it is
not permissible to go to the funeral of
a disbeliever or a person is not to bury
a disbeliever etc. This is under what
kind of circumstances?
Nor normal circumstances. But if a
person has an extreme set of
circumstances or circumstances that
don't match exactly what we mention here
then they need to ask right
why don't we teach exceptions
meaning we teach the rules but we don't
teach exceptions to the rules why
[Arabic recitation]
are the exception
that's why we do not teach the
exceptions publicly.
Exceptions are taught to scholars and
their students. They are not taught to
the general masses. Why? Because the
general masses are not equipped to judge
themselves an exception to the rule.
Everyone will think that he or she is
the exception to the rule. I'll give you
an example. The prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us
that a major sin is for a woman to ask
for divorce without due right from her
husband
the without having some extreme
circumstances to ask for a divorce.
every single woman and we have
instances in the sunnah where women have
asked for divorce and came to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
requested a divorce.
We teach what the general statements of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. It is
not permissible for a woman to seek
divorce without extreme circumstances,
extreme violence, extreme right. But are
there exceptions to this? Yes. But if we
teach those exceptions, every single
woman thinks that she is the exception.
Everyone.
Every single one.
These prohibitions are for somewhere
someone else. Same thing with men for
instance. That's a a common example,
right? Another example are issues of
issues of necessity. Something is haram,
right? Is haram. It is haram. It's haram
to take. It's haram to give. It's haram
to witness. It's haram to write.
Correct.
Are there exceptions, very remote
exceptions that could exempt a
person? Yes. Insurance? Haram. Are there
exceptions? Yes.
However, if we teach those exceptions,
what happens? Every single person thinks
that their situation is the exception,
right? Because they want to do it.
That's the issue.
And so the point that is made is that it
is incorrect. It is a disservice
to teach generally publicly exceptions.
That's not the place for it. You'll find
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam didn't
teach exceptions publicly. He taught
generalities publicly and exceptions.
When privately when someone comes to ask
him particular situation, particular
instance, he teaches the exception.
Right? And so it's important that if any
person has a set of circumstances that
are not exactly as we teach here, then
that person is to ask, right? they're
not to judge for themselves
if they are the exception or not.
The fifth type of in which it is
preferred that a person bathe and this
one is common and known to many of us
bathing for the two so the first of
and the 10th of
and the day of which is the 9th of these
are days in which bathing is preferred.
Why? And encouraged out of exaltation of
the time. Just we bathe on Friday,
it is an exaltation of the time.
Correct?
[Silence]
He says
for
[Silence]
he says
collects in his book Albe is a major
major scholar of the
he is a later scholar meaning in the 4th
century and he has a number of books but
one of them is
and in this book the scholars say listen
to this statement they say
[Silence]
is a major scholar of the a major
scholar of hadith. The scholars describe
Albe's work in the Med. They say a
he has done a service and a favor to
every that comes after him. And he is
owed by every she that comes after him
except for albe
has done a service and a favor and is
owed by himself. Why? Because of the
work that he did on
in collecting all of the narrations and
he served the med very very well in his
most prominent book.
There's a huge book of evidences for all
of the
and so
he narrates a narration in his on the
authority of a himself who narrates from
Zan. He said a man asked Ali
about
bathing
said bathe every day if you want to.
And so the man then said no I'm asking
about bathing meaning as an as a
worship.
And so
responded and said worship bathing as a
worship on occasions is bathing for the
day of jum bathing for the day of
bathing for the day of slaughtering and
bathing for the day of breaking the
fast. So these are five right
well there are four actually I said five
four
the 10th of
which is the day of slaughtering and the
first of which is
bathing this is for men women whether
you're going to or not going to whether
you're going out or not going out even
if a person is ill and they're able,
they get up, they walk to the bathroom,
they take a ba bath and they come back,
they have worshiped Allah by doing this.
Why? Because this is a type of
exaltation
of the days of Allah. Correct? And Allah
tells us that whoever exalts
the days and the rights and the holy
times and places of Allah then that is
from the piety of the hearts and that is
part of the exaltation of Allah himself.
[Arabic recitation]